again how's the gun dressed my name
welcome back to the very long lasting
social dad sign one chance playing on
the PlayStation so it's such a how do I
start like a slick playing PlayStation
sorry what the hell this is not funny
would you like to see the tutorial here
Kiera break into the mining office
we're playing us the dad and I don't
know why but we're playing SM at least
look at that period sky isn't that
lovely
I hope you can hear me well probably
meant to not be but it's okay alright Oh
left alright it's really loud I'm gonna
die a blood cancer alright let's try
this way whoa whoa don't dad's a problem
to cliff by holy [ __ ]
why does everyone want to dance in front
of Chris okay I guess it's this way then
Oh No
hi Yamaha I know I know a little jump on
and I'm not all sad Holly [ __ ] she's
awesome
oh she laughs like me too holy [ __ ] he's
like oh yeah now I'm gonna go and buy
some I don't know go play bingo like old
people like son of a [ __ ] she beat me
in the dance contest I'll show her with
my MJ moves
Oh No hey I love the pickaxe Hey all
right I'm so pumped
don't throw up your little [ __ ] never
again tonight everything is
fan-fucking-tastic here allowed to
system
oh no it's shaking can you feel this can
you feel no well probably in your pants
into place all right
sneaking she bought it without being
seen so we go over here I don't think we
can go there sound of a penis all right
staying quiet you can stop the sounds on
your first sight by crouching but I'm
already crouching all right whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hold on
of course it's like sex for him doing a
pickaxe aah
all right where the heck do I go now way
to hate my going find a weapon
picking up near what is this this is a
weapon it's a metal pipe I whatever it
will have to do some weapons cannot be
used by certain characters that's
[ __ ] lame
you can attack by oh I don't want to
kill people
oh no I used against my power my
superpower all right
I'm so sorry about this
I hope you're a zombie I'm gonna fire my
fireball your little batch ha ha ha just
I am double shifts at all finish it ha
ha like a boss
how do you like that how you like that
and how you like this Oh huh I like this
smack that all on the floor
like that Oh oh I fell on you I fell
right oh don't right in your butt oh I'm
so sorry
alright so now we go to what is the
objective can I go in here
you can break rusty locks by striking
them a few times I'm a charge em up pipe
singing I have a go like that all on the
food that's enough
I like [ __ ] you're pathetic I just going
here dr. pepper what the hell I was
mission accomplished
all right I made it I died that was a
mission
lovely all right that's all
oh I just we didn't see her than last
episode but he got shot by the police
and I guess he survived somehow that's
fantastic that's a lot of period oh no
damn Oh No baño are you alright
[ __ ] now you are you alright now
wait Don Tasha Miguel Wow goddamnit well
what a terrible wound can you walk it's
dangerous by yourself let me take your
horse looks really Swedish I'm just
saying alright
we're playing as Howard right probably
meant to my favorite escape if you
haven't realized yet this game is sort
of like a movie or a TV show on a very
special deal hi thank you I think my
penis is kind of big but not that big
haha
all right side jack on Anna's view I
guess our kid is all right left to
left - all right now look I always mix
up left and right I'm so sorry I know
people are gonna be like all right where
are okay there we go and then we locked
in her titties there we go you can all
what the hell is this look at death I
always wanted to see myself when I smack
the [ __ ] out of a girl I'm so sorry it's
against nut I'm not for hitting women
I was just whoa whoa whoa
what are you gonna do about this
situation girl no not what is she doing
she's freaking crazy all right you first
don't look at me like that don't look
what the hell are you doing get off me
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
like that I don't know Mingus and ASA
let's follow the lady hey some peeping
Bagon Bagon
it's lady in red taught me good I'm
backin the hell out of here and I'm like
oh my god oh my god my god
please follow me I am following you but
this sight thing is pissing me off can I
turn it off there we go much better all
right
now what what's going on here all right
oh where to jump haha I like every walk
jumps down from that [ __ ] huh I don't
care I don't care about anything I don't
care
whoa I don't care whoa aren't you here
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no es una
problema course I'm hi
oh no no I don't hide you must hide shut
up [ __ ] I know I must hide [ __ ] why do
I hide whoa whoa oh no I was just about
to hide slap that all on the floor slap
that gave me so much like that I'm out
of here all right lovely place you have
here I'm just gonna go outside people
yeah that's gonna go over here just can
go over here just gonna go all in here
lovely a long story all right
why the [ __ ] am i all right
I am peeing officially peeing in the
watching it feels nice and warm ro all
right it meant to not meet for tea what
if she dies it's not my fault no oh no
sin y'all not okay maybe it was my fault
I'm sorry baby suck at this game no I
don't it super gnarly
all right are you hurt let's hide here
Hana what's your side shut up I know I
was high oh oh no machine whoa oh hey
little late again I don't hug me
yeah cuz I act I [ __ ] laughs back off
Holly [ __ ] a head for a cop aren't you
don't you have enough I don't wanna -
you holy [ __ ]
I don't like head out she's gonna know
nothing monkey oh no no not the hard nut
to me oh she [ __ ] motorboat me to
death
all right now complain a beer don't get
killed
all right let's do the side Jack thing
all right current location on the map oh
I think we need to go around everything
again it's she dying again I swear to
God if she's dying it's like what the
[ __ ] do you want me to do she I I think
she's good
someone out there you see you bud yeah
she's that how the heck am I supposed to
find out that she's camping outside the
door
Bobcat bang you little [ __ ] oh whoa
whoa what am I doing here
how did I even get here hallelujah
can I save I want to save I don't want
to do this checkpoint thank you baby
Jesus
all right don't ever leave me I love you
it was so scary why are we jumping down
here
all right I'm just alright there we go
Vinita till the Congo I am escaped to
Korra wanna with our Nana what what's
your plan now she's right there
I need a queen in the battle plan watch
which sign that sign are you drunk are
you drunk
look at me when I'm talking to you are
you drunk fine Paul dick it's always
like this in the movie the girls like oh
can you do this I'm like no no I'm not
gonna do it
you know why I tell you what ah what the
hell are you doing
Wow don't slap me please please please I
made it so far I made it so far don't
slap me whatever you do but that all on
the floor like that give me take the
frying pan and I'm frying your face with
the pink that you got your name is Peter
Pan now back out why is he so I magia
there it's like you've done it depart
SATA and stop that stop that there you
go you don't go down to the ground I go
up
nice snappy soon I sure know there's the
side there's the side I I gotta say
something epic when I do it for all
prior letter [ __ ] hell yeah
alright alright where's she what is she
what's she doing that you should go
without me
look little [ __ ] son of a frying pan
I'm pissed now
he'd better not be down here hey y'all
alright [ __ ] made it
oh I like 1000 yes fine I'm here what do
you want go so far little girl I have a
frying pan I'll tell you doing are you
taking a piss
I know it's super awesome to do this
feature oh there's someone there
again snake pastor little [ __ ]
naca body
Rowlands possessed knockout the shoe
booth Dornier carry no I'm alright with
a trap
didn't I pick it up alright I picked it
up what do I do with that
all right I'm taking down how do I plant
the trap yes there we go
all right and now we poke him on his
Facebook wall you're back oh I got a
status update turn around
what oh I yell a little [ __ ] that's how
your app yeah that's how low silly pants
come here you little [ __ ] I show you
my did is I trick you you're not gonna
get any titties oh I get it you're mad
I'm bathing you're cheating anger I know
how it feels brother all right
and that's how it's done
mission accomplished I think on that
note we will entertain really see how
long I record it but it feels like
frickin Fukuyama like and favorite if
you enjoyed it really helps out a lot in
this good way from even though if you
want continue playing this or not leave
a comment about how much you love mine
if balls and that's pretty much it
potatoes hey you're not like that
you know I'm a penis [ __ ] this [ __ ]
what's going on here oh go back
whoa what the hell I am sucking PS right
now me too
but sexually ah